when I first looked at the script of The
Book Thief it was a role that seemed way
out of my traditional orbit he was such
a simple seemingly simple beautiful
character not as eccentric or as
flamboyant as some of the stuff I'd done
at the time I was working a lot in the
theater playing some outrageous roles
and I was really attracted to this new
rhythm it's like I have two children
while they're they're now young adults
and I would hate to say which one of
them was my favorite but probably I like
my job and I like working with groups of
people and I've been on films that have
been very very special to me in terms of
the group experience you know the short
list would be maybe Shakespeare in Love
quills The Book Thief King's Speech
wonderful teams but I suppose as an
actor when I did the life and death of
Peter Sellers simply because it was a
makeup fan that rocked because every day
I went in I would be dressing up as a
new character because
to have a chameleon personality I think
I had 28 weeks in about 60 different
voices of accents there was something
about the challenge of that that I found
a special
I don't want to act with dead people no
I wouldn't mind as a character actor
I wouldn't mind have been part of
Preston sturgis's ensemble back in the
40s these kind of crazy very off beat
films for a younger generation maybe in
that family tree that's where the Coen
brothers have picked up it's that kind
of field
look you can be lucky if you're lucky
enough to have a very special natural
gift Riza there's a chance that you will
be found that's what's happened with
Sophia at least I think on The Book
Thief
she's prodigiously gifted and she's in
the right place at the right time but my
advice is you train never forget there's
a great history and a heritage and a
craft to acting and you need to find out
how your imagination works because you
are the instrument and you have to know
how to play with that and the focus of
doing it through training is much better
than working randomly and not all the
time
you